today the Matt wall show a left-wing
media Outlet honors me with an
incredibly prestigious award it's a
great way to start the new year also an
NFL player collapses on the field 60
Minutes drops out an environmentalist
prophet of Doom who has been notoriously
wrong about literally everything for
decades The Usual Suspects dance on the
grave of Pope Benedict and the team
formerly known as the Washington
Redskins unveil their new mascot plus a
Libertarian publication is here to tell
us that we shouldn't be so worried about
children at drag shows it's all a moral
Panic they say all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
well if you're someone who has always
wanted to read and understand the Bible
but you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible and in your podcast
from Ascension the Bible in your podcast
is currently the most popular religion
podcast in the US millions of people
have listened to it and twice it's hit
the number one spot on Apple podcast in
the Bible and a year father Mike Schmitz
reads the entire Bible in 365 daily
episodes providing helpful commentary
reflection and prayer along the way what
better way to start the new year you can
find the Bible into your podcast with
father Mike Schmitz for free and your
favorite podcast app or on YouTube plus
you can follow along with a special
reading plan to help you better
understand the story unlike any other
Bible podcast Bible and ear follows a
special reading plan that organizes the
books of the Bible in a way that helps
listeners understand the story you can
get this reading plan at
ascensionpress.com Walsh if you want to
start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free that's
ascensionpress.com walls to download the
reading plan for free
as we begin the new year I believe it is
important to move forward to keep our
gaze fixed upon the Horizon we don't
want to spend too much time looking back
dwelling on the past yet I must say that
I do begin this year in a bit of a
reflective mood because 2022 was in many
ways a landmark year in my own life
began with uh my episode of Dr Phil in
early January a week after that episode
air I aired I was off to Africa filming
our at the time still secret documentary
project what is a woman which would be
released on the first day of pride month
in June of 2022 and go on to become one
of the most influential and talked about
documentaries of the current century in
the fall we exposed and brought down
Vanderbilt's child mutilation program
which led to our rally to end child
mutilation which was attended by upwards
of 3 000 people which led to the
introduction of legislation Banning
child gender transitions in the state of
Tennessee
all of that and we still found time to
do other things like raise awareness
about you know important issues like
translucent mermaids and satanic anime
so there's a lot going on in 2022 and
I'm very proud of all of those
accomplishments
and though I don't I don't I don't do it
for the awards I don't do it for the
accolades I still appreciate and am
humbled by them when they come which is
why I must take a moment to thank the
prominent left-wing publication the new
Republic which in the lead up to the new
year uh last week published a long
article awarding me
the title and trophy that I think I
worked very hard all year to earn this
is their headline
transphobe of the Year Matt Walsh the
right-wing writer and podcaster has
raised his profile by spreading
grotesque conspiracy theories about
grooming and pedophilia in the lgbtq
community
yes facing stiff competition from the
likes of Tucker Carlson and Chris Ruffo
in Libs of tick tock and others I was
still given the prestigious title of
transphobe of the year the writer Indigo
Olivier explains why the honor went to
me she writes quote from book bands to
bomb threats 2022 has been characterized
by a disturbing rise in right-wing
violence brought on by the viral moral
Panic of very online fear mongers and
the biggest target of this Mayhem has
been the transgender Community figures
like Libs of tick tocks Chaya reichik
Taco Carlson Ben Shapiro and the
Manhattan institute's Chris Ruffo have
joined conservative politicians in
flooding right-wing Airwaves with hate
speech and misinformation on issues like
gender affirming care and children's
sports but in a year when transgender
day of remembrance was marked by a mass
shooting at lgbtq nightclub in Colorado
Springs one man stands out from the
crowd Matt Walsh
I've already decided that I want this
person to deliver the eulogy at my
funeral which I think she'll be more
than happy to do actually but we're just
getting started it says quote the deli
wire columnist and podcast host has made
the name for himself by demonizing
medical professionals and pushing
conspiracy theories about grooming and
pedophilia in the lgbtq community if the
Club Q shooter is a lone wolf attacker
we should consider Walsh The Unofficial
pack leader while the bodies were still
warm the host of the Matt Walsh show
would log on to say quote if drag shows
are causing this much chaos and violence
why do you insist on continuing to do it
if according to you it's like putting
people's lives at risk if the effort to
have men cross-dress in front of
children is putting people's lives at
risk why are you still doing it it's a
crowded field but the new Republic has
crowned Walsh 2022's transphobe of the
year
So based on my reading of this it seems
that the transphobe of the Year
competition was it was very stiff
competition it came down to the wire at
the end and I finally pushed ahead of
the pack by making the exceedingly
obvious and basic observation documented
in that paragraph
which is that you know by the Groomer's
own account there has been Mass violence
and Chaos in response to drag
performances for children
now this account is entirely fictional
but that's beside the point the point is
that if it's true that exposing children
to drag
has caused this violent backlash
then you know it stands to reason that
one way to stop the violence would be to
Simply stop sexually harassing children
at drag shows
so if you really think that inviting
children to your drag show will put your
life at risk and yet you still do it
anyway
that only goes to show how totally
dedicated you are to grooming you're
apparently willing to Martyr yourself
for the cause
which just makes you all the more
deranged that's the point
anyway back to the article with a little
bit about my origin story it says Walsh
launched his fetid career in the same
manner as many of the worst of the
right-wing swamp conservative talk radio
Walsh has since gone on to create Johnny
The Walrus an allegorical children's
picture book about a boy who pretends to
be a walrus it reached number one on
Amazon's lgbtq bestsellers list and the
overall best sellers list by the way and
what is a woman a future length
documentary on gender ideology since his
early years in radio he's gone from a
bog standard shock jock vibe to a preppy
Fountain of increasingly weird far-right
obsessions Media Matters lgbtq program
director Arie Drennen has followed
Walsh's studied transformation which
he's changed his appearance based on his
audience
she said quote watching his early videos
it's really obvious that he wanted to
become famous today Walsh Sports a beard
and flannels and describes himself as a
Theocratic fascist on Twitter where he
has 1.2 million followers he says the
title can be interpreted in two ways
literally or as a joke
yes the people who are clinging
desperately onto my coattails reporting
on my every statement like I'm the pope
issuing infallible proclamations to the
faithful attaching themselves to me like
Barnacles on the side of a ship and
doing it all for clout
are concerned that I'm the one who is
trying too hard to be famous
and in their version of events okay in
their version of events I wanted to be
famous so much that I
grew a beard
and wore flannels
because everybody knows that's the first
step to fame and fortune
they they have it pegged I have to say
they've got it I can I still remember
the day A couple of years ago I'll never
forget I was thumbing through a Bass Pro
Shop catalog dreaming of one day
becoming wealthy and renowned when
suddenly my eyes fell on a Carhartt
flannel and I said to myself yes this is
it this is the ticket
and the rest is history
now I'm not going to read through too
much more of this but the next paragraph
I think is worth some attention it says
quote
I am literally a Theocratic fascist I do
indeed believe that my religious beliefs
should be forced on people by the
government and not just the government
but a government headed by me as a
dictator Walsh said in a 2019 video for
the daily wire before referencing his
recent Twitter tirade against white
condiments Mayo cream cheese ricotta
tartar sauce ranch dressing and my
Theocratic fascist dictatorship all of
those condiments will be confiscated
prohibited and anyone who's caught with
Contraband like say ranch dressing will
face execution and a 50 fine
are you in on the joke like I said this
guy is deeply weird
now I fail to see anything weird about
wanting to execute people who use ranch
dressing ranch dressing tastes like
buttermilk mixed with like pool water
okay it's disgusting
what else are we supposed to do with
ranch dressing users except kill them
I'm open to other Solutions but nobody's
offering any so I've started this
conversation I started years ago what do
we do about people using ranch dressing
I have one idea we could kill them all
if you have other
brainstorms that you want to throw out
there go ahead and do it
I'm just getting the conversation
started is all
back to the article one more time it
says this guy is deeply dangerous as
well Walsh's most disturbing narratives
have centered on children in August
after Walsh called for an organized
effort against medical facilities that
butcher children Boston Children's
Hospital home to the First Pediatric and
Adolescent transgender health program
received its first bomb threat
Walsh undeterred by the real world
effect of his fear-mongering continued
to push the claim that the hospital was
mutilating children
which I was pushing that claim by the
way because that's exactly what they
were doing so it's
pushing a client it's not really well
it's a claim but it's a claim of what's
actually
happening and so uh and and it really
wasn't a claim at all actually it was
more of a like pointing to see here's
here's what they're doing and here are
videos of them talking about what
they're doing
anyway it says when the hospital
received its second bomb threat in early
September Walsh claimed it was a false
alarm and he left us hoax before turning
his attention to Vanderbilt University
Medical Centers trans Health Clinic
Walsh is very much against the idea that
people should be free to be who they are
so much so that he's led a stochastic
Terror campaign against the trans
Community which he says he plans on
personally taking to the streets if the
proud boys are as some say modern day
brown shirts they may have found an
unlikely leader in Matt Walsh
yes that's me leader of the proud boys
I'm not sure that I've ever even met a
proud boy but I am their leader which
comes as news to them and also to me
but if you've listened to all of this so
far
and you've thought to yourself
well this isn't fair
I mean why are they just calling Matt a
trans Folk he's also a racist
don't worry they make sure to include
that Accolade at the end they say while
he reserves the worst hatred for the
trans Community Jason Campbell a senior
researcher at Media Matters says it's
important to point out that Matt Walsh
is also a racist he's becoming this
champion of white rights
they then make note of my translucent
mermaid activism before concluding with
this quote Walsh is ready to adapt on
the fly as various outrages and panics
split from fashionable to played out on
the right
quote I I don't think it's I don't think
this moment of anti-trans Hysteria is
going to last forever Drennan said I
would not be surprised if whatever the
next right-wing moral Panic is we see
Matt Walsh once again at the Forefront
having conveniently forgotten his
fixation on trans people
perhaps in years to come he'll find new
ways to take home tnr's accolades for
scoundrels
oh you can count on that I will find
many more ways to upset you in 2023 I
guarantee no question about it
except that if I could just
clarify one thing
I am not going to move on from
or forget
what you call my anti-trans hysteria
quote unquote until until the trans
movement has been totally and completely
destroyed that much I can promise you
I want it to be completely laying in Ash
in ruin that's what I want
now to that end we did make major
inroads last year the trans movement was
running rough shot over the culture for
years with basically no opposition and
that has now changed
and you on the left have noticed that
and you're panicking
and you're hoping that we'll be just
sort of happy with the battles we've won
so far and then we'll just move on to
something else
but your hopes are in vain
because we're out to win the entire War
and we will
so stay tuned
now let's get to our headlines
the current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation and if this is at odd
odds with your goals if you're tired of
the government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes so now you can own gold in a tax
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals all you
gotta do is text Walsh to 98 98 98 to
claim your free info kit on gold and
then talk to one of their precious metal
Specialists with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings but you got to text
Walsh to 98 98 98 and protect yourself
with gold today that's Tech that's Walsh
to 98 98 98 today
headline from The New York Times Demar
Hamlin of the Buffalo Bills in critical
condition after collapsing during during
an NFL game uh the article says Demar
Hamlin a 24 year old safety in his
second season with the Buffalo Bills was
in critical condition in a hospital
after going into cardiac arrest during a
Monday night game against the Cincinnati
Bengals according to the bills
team officials said in a statement early
Tuesday that Hamlin's heart stopped
after he was hit during a play in the
first quarter his heartbeat was restored
by medical personnel on the field before
Hamlin was taken to the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center adding uh
according to the bills again adding that
Hamlin was undergoing further testing
and treatment and had been sedated
about nine minutes into the game on
Monday night Hamlin tackled Bengals
receiver T Higgins after a 13-yard catch
Higgins rammed into Hamlin at full speed
hitting him in the head and chest area
Hamlin quickly stood up took two steps
and collapsed backwards and his body
went limp medical personnel administered
CPR and attended to him for 10 minutes
as players from both teams are visibly
upset
um and then eventually was taken on a
stretcher and transported to the
hospital all of this if you don't watch
football often maybe it still wouldn't
surprise you to learn that this is all
you know extremely unusual obviously for
someone to
have an injury and need need to be
attended to that's not unusual but to
see CPR being administered I don't think
I've ever seen that before uh in a
football game and being carted out by an
ambulance on the field is uh we have
seen that on occasion but that's very
rare so the two things together
um it's something we've never seen
before the game was suspended to be
rescheduled I'm not sure when at this
point and as of right now
you know last I heard Hamlin's vital
signs are back to normal but he's being
intubated with a breathing tube so
you know it's the good news is that he's
still alive and him still being alive
right now seemed very much in doubt last
night I think for people that were
watching it when it happened it you were
wondering if you just watched someone
die on a football field and um
right now it seems like
well I I don't want to speculate but he
has survived up to this point and uh and
hopefully you know his recovery will
continue
now of course
immediately after this happened
um
you started to see the speculation
online that this was
somehow related to the covid vaccine was
Hamlin suffering some kind of reaction
to the cover vaccine uh was this a
myocarditis situation
some people were asking you know some
people were asking that question was it
related to the vaccine other people were
getting very angry at the people who
were asking the question and there was a
lot of shouting and recrimination back
and forth and everybody was was very mad
so just another day on the internet as
far as that goes and here's what I'll
say about this
and I have one of those uh kinds of
opinions that that is sort of you know
maybe upset people on both sides at
least the unreasonable people on both
sides so on the one hand
there is no actual evidence that this
has anything to do with a vaccine
we don't even know if the player was
vaccinated okay that's a really
important detail here that that as far
as I know is not known he hasn't the
player has not announced that and uh he
hasn't announced it then you know that's
his medical right to privacy and so we
just don't know
um
there never was and this is maybe a
misconception people have there never
was a vaccine mandate in the NFL for
players
that was something that Aaron Rodgers
last year famously tested
um tested you know the the the the the
whether or not there there was a mandate
and he was able to unlike in the NBA for
example we had a few players that didn't
want to get vaccinated and they were
held out of games uh players that didn't
get vaccinated in the NFL they still
were able to play so there was never a
vaccine mandate which means that
just because a player is in the NFL we
can't assume that they're vaccinated
it's possible that he wasn't
um and
even if he was vaccinated it also
doesn't make sense to just assume that
the two things are related just because
you have two data points you have he
collapsed on the field and he was
vaccinated in order to
you know draw a link of causation you
need more information than we currently
have
and and besides the Assumption might
have a bit more weight if he had just
collapsed randomly while running down
the field but that's not what happened
uh the fact is that he suffered a blow
directly to the chest right before he
collapsed
and and it does people have were saying
online I've been saying since it
happened that it looks like a relatively
normal sort of tackle that you see looks
Garden variety you know it looks like a
normal thing you see in the NFL all the
time which is true but keep in mind that
a normal tackle in the NFL can still be
a collision roughly equivalent to a car
crash so normal doesn't really mean
anything
we also know that there is a rare
condition
uh it's it's it's rare but it's very
real and it's been known about for many
years where somebody in an athletic
setting gets hit in the chest at exactly
the wrong moments
in exactly the wrong part of their chest
and then um and then it it interrupts
the heart's Rhythm and it causes Cardiac
Arrest that is a real thing it's called
Uh uh commodio Cordis now I I never
heard of that until last night and the
thing is like another thing about the
internet obviously is uh people are
introduced to a concept and 30 seconds
later they're experts in it so last
night there were a lot of commodio
Cordis experts on Twitter I'm not one of
them I don't know anything about it I
learned about it last night
but it is apparent that this is a thing
that exists
it's been documented it does happen it's
again rare but rare that's the thing
about something that's rare it happens
doesn't happen often but it does happen
and you can see the video I think we
have the video of uh of this let's just
put this up not the video part where
he's collapsing but you see where he's
hitting the chest go ahead and play this
so he's hitting the chest right there
and you can see his body kind of fold
around the hit so that is a yeah as well
as a normal hit in the NFL yeah it's a
normal hit but that is a full speed
jolt right to the chest and that it's
it's not
unreasonable to think that that could
really hurt someone obviously
um now
on the other hand
you cannot blame people
for asking the vaccine question
okay it's it is it is not reasonable to
get upset when people are asking about
the possibility of a connection here
you can't blame them because first of
all it is a potential Factor
that doesn't mean that it's
that it's a real Factor it doesn't mean
that that it's an actual Factor but it's
a potential when you look at all the
possibilities here uh there's a lot of
potential we don't have a lot of
information so all we have right now is
potential
and that is one of the potential factors
uh the potential is there
and so people are going to wonder about
Potentials in a situation like this
besides even if you think that the
vaccine issue is a total non-factor
the fact is that millions of people are
thinking it anyway
whether you think they should be
thinking it or not they are
so that's just as soon as this happened
um
immediately millions of people are
thinking does this have something to do
with the vaccine
now my point is that like if millions of
people are thinking it
the idea that it's wrong to verbalize
what millions of people are thinking and
having their heads already is just
absurd
what's why why get upset about that
you know people are thinking and
wondering it's so like we're not allowed
to talk about the thing that's in our
heads anyway
for what reason
and by the way if you're concerned about
so-called conspiracy theories and people
uh engaging in what you consider to be
um
conjecture and all the rest of it you
know shouting people down when they
bring this up is not the way
to you know address that
also the other thing is we've been lied
to right again and again and again we've
been lied about to about the vaccine
about the virus about everything
and that makes people suspicious
it makes people more likely to engage in
speculation
this is the consequence of a lack of
trust
and the lack of trust is the fault of
the public health authorities that now
chastise the people who are speculating
but it's their fault
see I don't blame people for speculating
because what else are they going to do
wait for a trusted authority to tell us
well who is that exactly who's the
trusted Authority at this point
where is this mythical person they don't
exist
so when you have a lack of trust uh you
know we don't trust the public health
authorities so-called you don't trust
the media and they're the ones that are
supposed to be disseminating uh this
information
and when that happens all that's left
you just you just you just you have an
environment where people are just kind
of on their own
imagining scenarios
but certainly not ideal but it's it's
inevitable
and I don't blame the people who are
imagining these scenarios I blame the
people who have created this
catastrophic lack of trust
so that's how that all breaks down
um
all right let's uh
let's move to this headline from the
daily wire
stand firm in the faith hope Benedict to
the 16th final message to the faithful
uh now we missed some some major news
events over the break and uh
this is one that I think is worth
circling back to Pope Benedict of course
passed away at age 95 on New Year's Eve
uh a day after I believe he was day
after Barbara Walters died in 93. so
here's the daily wire report Pope
emaratus Benedict the 16th told
Catholics to stand firm in the faith in
his final message to the faithful the
Vatican published a late Pope's
spiritual Testament shortly after his
death on Saturday in it Benedict thanked
his family his friends and God for the
blessings of his life and asked
forgiveness from anyone who he had
wronged he then urged Believers to stand
strong in the faith even in the face of
philosophical and scientific opposition
he wrote quote if in this late hour of
my life I look back at the decades I had
been through first I see how many
reasons I have to give thanks first and
foremost I thank God himself The Giver
of every good gift who gave me life and
guided me through various confusing
times always picking me up whenever I
began to slip and always giving me again
the light of his face in retrospect I
see and understand that even the dark
and tiring stretches of this journey
were for my salvation that it was in
them that he guided me well he went on
to thank his parents for providing him
with a loving home and role models for
his faith he also thanked his brother
and sister for caring for and guiding
him through his life he also thanked his
friends colleagues and former students
Benedict then instructed Catholics to
remain true to the faith in the face of
opposition from science and philosophy
he wrote stand firm in the faith do not
let yourselves be confused it often
seems that science the Natural Sciences
on the one hand and historical research
especially especially exegesis of sacred
scripture on the other are able to offer
irrefutable results at odds with
Catholic faith I've experienced the
transformations of the Natural Sciences
since long ago and I've been able to see
how on the contrary the parent
certainties against the faith have
vanished proving to be not science but
philosophical interpretations only
apparently pertaining to science he also
noted that science helps to better
Define the parameters of faith and the
whole the whole uh
statement from him his final words are
certainly worth reading and go do that
um
you know as for my own thoughts on
Benedict I would just say that he was
first of all a great Theologian and I
read a few of his books Jesus of
Nazareth was my favorite of his actually
it's multiple volumes
um about the life of Jesus
and the important thing about benedict
for my money is not just that he was
orthodox
a defender of Orthodoxy but that he was
able to write
and speak
beautifully and clearly and in a way
that people could understand
there have been a lot of great
um
theologians through the history of the
church who
have incredible insight to offer but you
need to already have like a PhD in
theology to understand what they're
saying that was not the case for Pope
Benedict and as for his axis Pope he
welcomed back the Latin Mass oversaw the
re-emergence of the most traditional and
reverent form of the mass now it's true
that a lot of that is being undone right
now by his predecessor unfortunately but
the key thing is that in making that
change he facilitated a a wave of young
people and young families coming into
the church
people who were looking for something
sacred something
reverence something mystical and found
it in the Catholic church under Pope
Benedict so even if Francis is trying
his level best to ruin all of that I
don't think he can do undo all of it and
even despite his best efforts
but
the challenge with Benedict the
difficulty I have with him
is that is that he left he retired he
gave the church over to Francis and and
yet obviously was not on his deathbed
when he left because he lived another
decade
and it's hard for me to that's the thing
that's hard for me to reconcile
um because I think that Pope Francis is
pontiff has been such a papacy has been
such an absolute disaster
and you have Benedict who stepped aside
and remained
relatively silent as Francis executed
his reign of confusion and moral
Insanity that's been ongoing for a
decade now
so that's the part that for me is
extremely difficult but all in all
you know a great life a life of great
consequence
so naturally of course that means that
uh leftists on social media and in the
corporate media they were dancing on his
grave when he died I'm not going to go
through and read examples you can
imagine
um just posting the most vile and
hateful things
one note I will make about that though
is that obviously it's not especially
surprising that they would react this
way to a pope dying especially that Pope
because he's known to be conservative
Orthodox and so they hate him
reflexively for that they don't need to
know anything else about him and they
don't
but they know that they know that that
he's Catholic he's a pope and that he
was you know associated with being
conservative and so that's enough reason
to hate him
um but this is a trend now I think
when most famous people especially older
famous people die same thing happened
with Queen Elizabeth
more often than not now
the death of a significant person
is met with jeers and mocking and
ridicule and jokes
I think it's partly ideological
but it's partially the people that are
dancing on the graves you know they
associate the dead person with an
ideology that they abhor and so that's
part of why they're doing it but the
other part of it is that I think
it's the fact that this that the
significant person was significant
it's the significance itself that they
hate and loathe and resent
I really think we're entering an age now
we're in an age actually where greatness
is despised
per se
like people hate greatness just because
it's greatness
so you know you have these people that
they'll
they'll mourn when some irrelevant 22
year old rapper gets shot right they'll
mourn that some drugged out nobody who
created garbage glorified violence then
died by the violence he glorified that
will provoke solemn mourning from these
people
but precisely because
the guy their morning didn't do anything
he became moderately famous for babbling
incoherently in a couple of songs that
made it onto their Spotify playlist and
that's it and they'll mourn a guy like
that because he didn't commit the sin of
achieving anything significant
but I think if you live a long life
and you achieve significant things and
you do great things
um you're going to be hated just for
that reason alone
there's a lot of resentment there's a
lot of resentment and jealousy I think
mixed up in in that
but um
that's what it comes down to
which is why really at this point the
greatest honor that we could all hope to
achieve
is uh is that when we die our death will
be celebrated on Twitter
because that means that you did
something significant because that's the
that's the price you pay ultimately
um
let's see
here's a headline from CBS News
scientists say the planet is in the
midst of a sixth mass extinction Earth's
Wildlife are running out of places to
live
so this is pretty remarkable not the
headline the headline is remarkably
bogus
what's remarkable is that 60 Minutes did
a report on this uh supposed
environmental crisis which is completely
fake by the way
but one of the key interviews in this
report I think has people talking and
talking for
all the reasons that 60 Minutes doesn't
want but let's watch a little bit of
this first
finding solutions to the problems was
the goal two weeks ago at the U.N
biodiversity conference where Nations
agreed to conservation targets
but at the same meeting in 2010 those
Nations agreed to limit the destruction
of the Earth by 2020 and not one of
those goals was met
this despite thousands of studies
including the continuing research of
Stanford biologist Paul Ehrlich you know
that there is no political will to do
any of the things that you're
recommending
I know there's no political will to do
any of the things that I'm concerned
with which is exactly why I and the vast
majority of my colleagues think we're
we've had it that the next few decades
will be the end of the kind of
civilization we're used to in the 50
years since ehrlich's population bomb
Humanities feasting on resources has
tripled we're already consuming
175 percent of what the Earth can
regenerate and consider half of humanity
about 4 billion live on less than ten
dollars a day they aspire to cars air
conditioning and a rich diet
yes Paul Ehrlich this is a guy who's had
an illustrious career of being wrong
that's been his job for decades to just
be wrong and he's been wrong about
everything he has predicted dozens of
armageddons and been wrong about all of
them without fail
now to his credit
slightly he at least has the gumption to
make specific predictions
yeah and I think that the uh
the environmental doomsayers the climate
change chicken littles these days
they've they've learned their lesson and
they're much more sort of vague and
Broad and the things that they're saying
are ambiguous and kind of they make
these amorphous claims that you know
it's like
that no matter what happens with the
weather it it automatically validates
whatever they just said so that's what
they do these days always ready to pull
their punch
but he didn't do that he was very
specific about this is how many people
are going to die this is when they're
gonna die and all of that uh he wrote
the book the population bomb in the 60s
which you know foretold a future in
which hundreds of millions would die
from starvation because there are too
many people on earth
and he said again he was he was specific
he said this would happen in the 1980s
but it didn't and we're now in the 2020s
and we have 8 billion people on earth
and his apocalypse still has not come to
fruition
the Federalist has an article about this
uh read a little bit from this says his
1968 book the population bomb is among
the most destructive of the 20th century
the long screen not only made Ehrlich a
celebrity but gave end-of-day alarmist
say uh patina of uh scientific
legitimacy popularized alarmism as a
political tool and normalized
authoritarian and anti-humanist policies
as a cure ehrlich's progeny or other
media favored hysterics by other
anti-humanists such as Al Gore Greta
thunderberg who skipped learning history
and science because she also believes
we're on the precipice of mass
extinction and none of this is to
mention thousands of other little
ehrlichs nudging you to eat insects
gluing themselves to roads and demanding
you surrender the most basic
conveniences and necessities of
modernity
um the battle to feed all of humanity is
over the opening line of the population
bomb reads in the 1970s hundreds oh
sorry so he predicted the 70s not the
80s when this would happen in the 1970s
hundreds of millions of people will
starve to death in spite of any crash
programs embarked upon now Ehrlich wrote
it was likely he went on that the oceans
would be without Life By 1979 and the
United States would see its population
plummet to 23 million by 1999 due to
pesticides
the death rate will increase until at
least 100 to 200 million people per year
are starving to death during the next 10
years
he said and uh he was wrong about all
that
the oceans will be without life
now there's a bulb again
maybe slightly to his credit he made
bold predictions and he put and he put a
he put a date on it he said by this date
this is what will happen
and he also claimed that not that there
was nothing that could be done to
prevent this
which means that he can't say now that
oh well I was you know I was only wrong
about that because uh because I made
this prediction and then people
mobilized and uh and we averted it
well you said it can't be averted
so now they've carded this guy's carcass
out of its Crypt so that he can rattle
off some more doomsday prophecies
which is just uh amazing
and as mentioned in the headline one of
the prophecies that he's now making is
that war on the verge of a of a of a a
sixth greatest Extinction event
where lots of um
species on Earth are going to go extinct
Michael schellenberger on his sub stack
has more on on the specific claims being
made by Ehrlich this time he says on CBS
60 Minutes last night scientists claim
that humans are causing a six mass
extinction that we would need the
equivalent of five Planet Earths for all
humans to live at current Western levels
he continues to cause a mass extinction
humans would need to be wiping out 75 to
90 percent of all species on Earth
the international Union for conservation
of nature the main scientific body that
track species says just six percent of
species are critically endangered nine
percent are endangered and 12 percent
are vulnerable to becoming endangered
further the iucn has estimated that just
0.8 percent of the 1000 about the about
the you know a little over a hundred
thousand plant animal insect species
within its data set have gone extinct
since 1500.
so that's in the last 500 years
0.8 percent have gone extinct
and when you hear figures like this you
also have to always remember that like
99 of the species that ever existed on
Earth had already gone extinct by the
time Human Being Human civilization came
about
uh that's a rate it continues that's a
rate of fewer than two species lost
every year for an annual Extinction rate
of .001 percent
so
this uh claim is just total nonsense
you know not only are we not bringing
about this mass extinction but human
beings
are also working to
conserve animal species there are animal
species that are around today and would
not be if not for for us
now you know the classic example that I
always bring up are pandas but that's
they're not the only ones
but that's it's it's a good example no
matter how you feel about pandas it's a
it's a good example to bring up here
because
um
they would be extinct not because of us
not because of deforestation or whatever
but just because of their own lack of
effort okay pandas if if human beings
did not exist at all pandas would not
exist either
so they are one of the species that we
are keeping around through our
conservation efforts
but as always with the left like they
they uh no matter what victories they
claim they can never actually claim the
victory they can't actually celebrate
anything
so they call themselves Progressive but
even if they achieve
progress in a certain area
um part of the whole game here part of
the gimmick is to claim is to is to
claim that we're constantly in a state
where no progress has been made at all
we're constantly in a in a crisis all
the time
and this is the case with in the
environmental Arena this is the case
when it comes to race everything else
so we're in a crisis
they put forward all of these solutions
to solve the crisis
but it's already been decided ahead of
time that no none of those Solutions can
actually work because they need the
crisis
that's what they need most of all
right one other thing uh to mention here
is the headline from NBC Washington meet
major Tudy the Washington Commander's
new mascot so they got rid of the
Redskins
and um
then it took him a little while and they
finally settled on the commanders as the
new name and now they have finally come
up with their new mascot let's look at
this guy here's the new mascot that they
introduced this is Commander or no major
Teddy
[Applause]
[Music]
military uniform
[Applause]
you know there's a
okay that's the new and improved mascot
you know there's a there's a there's a
barbecue restaurant chain that my dad
used to be obsessed with and I'm not
sure if it even exists anymore but it
was called uh Red Hot and Blue it was a
regional thing I don't know if it still
exists anyway this pig looks like that
restaurant's mascot this is literally a
cartoon pig mascot from a regional
barbecue joint and that's what they're
going with
and by the way how is this less
offensive than what they had before this
is a pig in a kind of like vaguely
military uniform with a military title
somehow he's obtained the rank of major
we don't know how
I'm not saying I'm offended by it but
it's just like isn't this more obnoxious
and crass than the Indian they had
before
which is why I will continue to dead
name the Washington Redskins
they will remain the Redskins to me I I
cannot be a party to this I cannot be a
party to Major tuddy
this is how it goes right they get rid
of something traditional something with
meaning and they replace it with just
the dumbest crap you've ever seen they
replace it with a dancing pig in a
military uniform that's the Improvement
that's progress
let's get to the comment sections
[Music]
all right well hopefully you had a a
good Christmas break if you had a
Christmas break at all um I really
enjoyed mine I have to say we we have
the pregnancy card to play so which
meant that our family we didn't have to
travel for the holidays everyone had to
come to us and uh so we got to stay at
home and that made things easier and we
got about a half inch of snow
here in Nashville was like negative two
degrees for a couple days and uh and
that wasn't going to stop us from from
going out and doing some sledding you
know and when I say us I mean us because
obviously
I'm not sending my kids out alone as
always it's my deep and solemn
responsibility as a father
hi my kids know this at this point I got
to do a safety check on all the sleds so
I gotta go out
and this is just it's one of those
things you got to do as a dad and I had
to sled down all the Hills first and all
the on all the different sleds
and keep doing periodic safety checks
um it's similar similar to the health
checks that I do on Halloween candy
you have to make sure that they're not
poisoned or whatever so doing plenty of
safety checks and that plenty of safety
checks on my kids toys they got for
Christmas
and I know we just talked about before
the break that uh you know adults need
to grow up and stop playing with toys
but this was different because I'm a
father
and I have to make sure my kids are okay
so for example they got these uh those
hoverboard things
um
they're not really hoverboards they're
they're actually just like they're like
Segways but without handlebars so they
got those and uh I was driving them
around quite a bit all week continually
checking to make sure that everything's
okay making sure that the that
everything's working fine that it's not
going to explode when you step on it
that's what I had to do and ironically
it turned out that the hoverboards were
extremely safe for my kids but not for
me because I am I sustained probably
three or four injuries serious ones from
uh playing on the hoverboards not
playing on them checking them for safety
anyways over the comment section today
it's it's been over a week since the
last show and rather than pulling
comments from that show
um because it's you know old news now
I'll pull from one of the pieces of
content that we posted to YouTube during
the break and this is the most important
one I think where I was forced to try
vegan milk and cookies
it was a vegan milk and cookie taste
test and that video is up right now
again very important content like
everything we post on YouTube and so
here are some comments from that because
why not Sean says after trying the vegan
milk and cookies Matt Walsh suddenly is
unable to Define what a woman is merry
Christmas everybody
says dirt
get punked says Matt's new film is going
to be what is milk and I don't need that
film because that's that's an easy
question to answer
uh
and as I explain that video
milk is something that is secreted from
a mammal okay that's that's one of the
most
it's not one of the it's not the only
thing you'd be secreted but it's it's it
in order to be milk to begin with it has
to be a mammal secretion
and I understand that you know we might
not like to think of it that way and you
don't want to see when you go to buy the
two percent gallon of milk you know at
the grocery store you don't want it to
say mammal secretion on it but that's
what it is and my only point is that
when you hear about coconut milk or
almond milk or or you know soy milk or
whatever
none of that is actually milk because by
definition it was not secreted from a
mammal as I explained that is not a
mammal secretion that is nut juice that
is juice from a nut and so you have nut
juice versus mammal secretion
two completely different things
Jorge says I'm not vegan but a friend
once made vegan cookies and they were
top three best tasting chocolate chip
cookies I ever ate
couldn't tell the difference and
extremely chewy
well that just tells me something Jorge
about all the people who are making you
regular chocolate chip cookies up until
that moment
and that is a very sad life that you've
lived
um
erdoc says almond milk is actually
really good I grew up on whole milk only
but got tired of my milk going bad
fairly fast now I don't even think about
it when I drink it
you know what if you want to claim that
you enjoy almond juice almond nut juice
that's fine but just don't compare it to
this two completely different things
that's my only point
um
Kyle says why is it so entertaining to
watch Matt so miserable I don't know but
people seem to enjoy it
Chris says I feel like these bits make
up for all the times Matt weasels his
way out of punishments like interpretive
dance and watching anime okay first of
all I didn't weasel my way out of
interpretive dance for the millieth time
I actually did it and there's video
evidence of it and as far as anime
I've already said
I tried to get out on a technicality and
uh and you know I believe in the in the
letter of the law and the spirit of the
law there's a letter and a spirit
and if I can get out of something it's
not really getting out of it but if I
can if the if the letter of the law
offers me an escape hatch I will take it
okay I believe in this across the board
I believe in this when you're like
paying your taxes
that's right it's like it's like if if
the law offers you a way to pay less
taxes take advantage of it why shouldn't
you
but I have been informed that uh my
efforts
didn't even live up to the letter of the
law which means that I still have to
watch the anime and I will so you can
stay tuned for that today is January 3rd
or as I like to call it the day where
most New Year's resolutions come to a
screeching halt well here's one
resolution you'll want to keep and
that's subscribing to daily wire plus if
you didn't take advantage of our 30 off
holiday membership sale we've extended
it until today this is your very last
chance to get 30 off new daily wire plus
annual memberships and gift memberships
when you go to dailywired.com Walsh in
some ways 2022 was the definition of
success for me as we talked about the
start of the show my best-selling
children's book Johnny The Walrus the
triumphant reception of my documentary
what is woman and our rally to enshaw
mutilation which put leftists on notice
everywhere that we are United against
destructive gender ideology but 2023 is
going to be even bigger for daily wire
plus you'll be seeing kids content that
you'll actually want your kids to watch
the Pendragon cycle will also get a
release later in the year and will
continue to stand up to leftist tyranny
you you're going to want to be a part of
all of this and everything else we got
coming up today is your last chance to
get 30 off annual memberships and gift
memberships by using Code holiday at
checkout so I head to dailywire.com
walls right now and let's get now to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so one thing we know about our friends
over at reason which is the libertarian
publication is that they are very
concerned about moral panics they want
to make sure that
nobody is engaging in a moral Panic it's
just that to them
anyone who demonstrates any moral
concern over any issue at all is
automatically guilty of a moral panic
it is impossible to make a moral
argument of any kind about anything
without being charged with a moral Panic
from people like this unless you're
having a moral Panic about moral panics
in which case it's not a moral panic
so those are the rules they don't make
any sense but those are the rules and
that brings us to an article published
by reason shortly before the new year
written by Scott shackford entitled
the fight over kids at drag shows is a
classic moral panic shackford writes
quote of course Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis and his administration would
contribute to the latest
Christmas-themed targeting of drag
queens as some existential threats the
state Department's uh the the State's
Department of Business and Professional
Regulation sent a letter Wednesday to
the Orlando Philharmonic Plaza
Foundation or in Orlando Florida because
their venue was hosting a drag queen
Christmas which is a touring Stage
production crossing the country that's
been around for eight years the letter
warns that the venue that they they have
reason to believe that this drag show is
of a sexual nature involving the
exposure or exhibit or exhibition of
sexual organs simulated sexual activity
and or the sexualization of children's
stories
note that this letter doesn't actually
say that there is any nudity or
simulated sexual activity at the show
only the department believes that there
is it probably consulted this Twitter
thread by Taylor Hansen who provides
images and clips of the show from its
stop in Austin Texas
a drag queen Christmas is a pretty
raunchy show in the way that's familiar
to anybody who has watched drag
performances but the only nudity found
in Hanson's clips and images is a pair
of absolutely fake boobs being worn by a
drag queen there's a lot of overtly
sexualized behavior and gyrating from
people who are not actually naked or
having sex
ah so you see
shackford is offering important context
here the male cross-dresser was only
flaunting prosthetic breasts in front of
small children not real ones
and although there was lots of
sexualized behavior as he says None of
the performers were fully naked and
besides they were only simulating sex in
front of children they weren't actually
having sex
now how does this make any of it okay
well because shackford can compare this
thing to some other thing and we all
know if you can compare one thing to
another thing then the thing must be
fine this is internet debating 101 here
okay he continues essentially this is a
Madonna concert Circa her Blonde
Ambition World Tour days but Don of
course is famously beloved by gay men
and drag queens in particular for her
wild looks and deliberately sexualized
Persona she was threatened with arrest
in Toronto back in 1990 for simulating
masturbation during her live performance
of like a virgin though police
eventually backed down there was a moral
Panic then that children exposed to
Madonna's Antics were being sexualized
at a young age funny how some things
don't change
now
there are so many egregiously stupid
arguments in this piece that I don't
want to get hung up on any one of them
for too long but I do need to take a
moment to let this part absorb because
this is a classic move of child
sexualization apologists otherwise known
as groomers
they love to point out that kids in
earlier decades were exposed to sexual
content too and uh well look how well
they turned out
except that the astute Observer might
note that those kids in fact
did not turn out well
indeed the people who were having a
moral Panic about Madonna in the 80s and
90s claiming that the coarsening of
culture the over sexualization the
profanity and debauchery would put us on
a slippery slope into full-on cultural
depravity
they were 100 right
they didn't even know how right they
were
even they couldn't imagine that in
another 30 years there would be
family-friendly drag shows with
cross-dressing half-naked men simulating
anal sex in front of toddlers
so critics three decades ago they were
not engaged in a panic but rather were
issuing a prophetic warning about the
state of and direction of the culture
a warning that the Scott shackfords of
the world world have always been quick
to blow off because the Scott shackfords
of the world are always wrong about
everything
back to the article the the wrong man
writes quote if I had small children I
probably would not take them to the show
but what's clear from Hanson's clip is
that several parents did voluntarily and
seem to know that this was going to
happen it doesn't appear that there's
actual nudity in the show and the amount
of sexualization would put it at maybe
an R rating if it were in a movie movie
what we have here is a lot of screaming
and politicization about families making
entertainment decisions other adults do
not like
this is flat out a moral panic and a few
lines later he continues
but this is not a moral Panic some
insist there is a limit to the parents
rights argument and this this all
crosses a line parents should not be
allowed to take their kids to live drag
shows to that I say by looking at the
behavior here in the public response to
it we can see that just as with Madonna
this is a moral panic
well at least we can all agree that
Scott whatever else you might say about
him is a tremendous and persuasive
writer
this is a moral Panic some people say
it's not a moral Panic to that I say
this is a moral panic
truly a compelling composition I have to
say he concludes quote claiming that
drag shows are different is a subjective
evaluation based on how a person feels
about exposure to drag performances it's
an attempt to force one group of
people's parental choices on the
collective and the Mindless tossing
around of the word groomer is just an
epithet designed to shut down opposition
on the belief that nobody wants to be
accused of supporting child sexual abuse
it's a reminder of back during the 1970s
through the 1990s When anybody who was
not heterosexual was regularly accused
of trying to recruit kids moral panics
about gay people interacting with
children are hardly new we have laws
about minors and nudity and sexually
explicit live performances and we have
parents to make decisions for stuff that
falls just on the legal side of that
line that's how it has been for the
longest of times and drag queens don't
change that calculus if you don't want
your children to see this stuff don't
take them leave everybody else alone
so once again we have the historical
comparison that only helps to validate
the very concerns he's trying to dismiss
because he points out that a few decades
ago
some people were concerned that the gay
agenda was recruiting kids
okay fast forward to our current time
and we see that LGBT identification
doubled in the millennial generation and
then doubled again for Gen Z
so all of the evidence strongly suggests
that the recruitment efforts were not
only real but incredibly effective and
still ongoing
so what is shackford's actual argument
well
there really isn't anything in this
lengthy diatribe that deserves to be
dignified with the label of argument but
the closest he gets is when he points
out repeatedly that parents make the
decision to bring their kids to drag
shows it's an it's an entertainment
Choice as he says
if you don't want your own kids to be
spectators at a drag themed sex show
then don't bring them
leave those other parents alone
this is what passes for an argument
among Libertarians simply pointing out
that something is a choice is automatic
justification of the choice
a choice is valid because it was chosen
they think
but that is completely incoherent of
course
yes we all recognize that some parents
choose to expose their children to this
sort of sexual content yes that that's
established
but the question is not about whether
it's a choice but rather about the
nature of the choice
and in this case they are making the
choice to subject their children to
sexual grooming
that is not a valid choice
it's not a morally acceptable Choice it
should not be a legally permissible
choice
and when it comes to drag shows by the
way Choice only works as an excuse if
we're talking about the choice that
adults make to expose themselves to such
content
okay so we're talking about adults at a
drag show
then it might be good enough to just say
well all the people here chose to be
here and this is what they want to see
now even that argument is not decisive I
don't think
because just because people choose to do
something doesn't make it automatically
okay there's still a conversation to be
had
but but the point is that here we're
talking about the choice
that adults make to expose another party
another person a child to this content
it is a choice being made for and on
behalf of somebody else
and that someone else cannot legally
consent to being involved in this
activity
so so this is not actually a question of
personal choice at all this is the the
the person that issue the child cannot
choose
the child therefore does not choose to
be at the drag show
so the drag show is something that
happens to the child it's being done to
him he is brought there against his will
he's exposed to these images and ideas
against his will
because again even if the child says
yeah I want to go
he's a child you can't consent
the question then is whether parents
have the right
to do whatever they want to their kids
and whether this right supersedes the
child's right to be protected from harm
and only a moral idiot and a pervert
would answer yes to a question like that
which explains Scott shackford's
position on the subject
and that is why he is
today first one of the Year canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]